April is autism acceptance month in the
past 20 years the number of autism cases
in U.S children has more than tripled
and new CDC numbers show that they're
still going up in 2020 about 1 in 36
eight-year-olds were diagnosed with
autism spectrum disorder that's up from
1 in 44 in 2018. also for the first time
in 2020 higher percentages of Asian and
Pacific Islander Hispanic and black
children were diagnosed then white
children autism spectrum disorder is a
developmental disorder that can affect a
child's social skills communication and
behavior clinical psychologist Cynthia
Martin from the child MIND Institute
joins us right now good morning Cynthia
how are you doing good morning doing
well so 22 percent rise in autism cases
in two years may seem concerning to most
but you say it's a good thing yeah well
one thing that I think we want to also
be aware of is that we are coming out of
a global pandemic where there were a lot
of numbers that were going out so any
numbers that are going to affect
children are going to have parents on
high alert so but these numbers
detecting autism identifying autism
within our broader Community is
something that has been underway for
years and for decades and what these
numbers are in part reflective of is
better detection of autism and not just
detection but actually taking those
children who are detected of happy
autism and getting them linked with a
medical provider or getting them
identified within a school system is
actually having Autism Spectrum Disorder
so this rise in diagnosed cases of
autism is a positive thing because we
also know that we are better identifying
children who are coming from underserved
communities or children of minority
racial groups who were not previously
identified in Prior samples that led to
the CDC data okay go ahead so I think
we're going to ask the same question I
want to know what are some of the signs
if you're a parent and you're watching
your child especially because I keep
hearing they're fine until two or three
years old and then all of a sudden they
start to regress a is that true and B
what are some of those signs that
parents should be looking out for yeah
that's a great question so um we
typically don't see that kids are
developing
a hundred percent typically and then at
two they have a severe regression so
that's a bit more of a misconception
what a lot of parents think about when
they think about autism but we are much
much better at identifying autism in
really young kids so as young as about
12 months we can start seeing some
children having some deviations in what
we call their joint attention skills so
what that looks like is you see that the
child isn't really paying attention to
the same things you're paying attention
to or it's really difficult to get their
attention so it doesn't point to people
play with others respond to their name
make eye contact right so they it might
be difficult to get their attention by
calling their name they also might not
be communicating with you a lot so
toddlers are primed to communicate you
should know what they're thinking what
they're feeling what they want without
them needing to verbally tell you
because they're going to tell you
through their facial expression or
through pointing or gesturing or showing
you things or giving you things and
that's not something that we typically
need to teach young kids so if young
children under the age of two are not
doing that then you do want to bring
those concerns to your pediatrician and
potentially consider an evaluation where
are we on the question of what's causing
autism that's a good question and I only
get that question about five times every
day
um and we well then you're welcome
I hope this is the first yeah this is
the first one for for today and the
reality is we just don't know yet we
don't know what causes autism that's so
scary that after all this time and as
prevalent as it it seems to be that we
still don't know I was curious about why
it's higher among people of color and in
boys
so the for people of color I don't
necessarily think it's higher you don't
then it's I think what we see in the CDC
data right now is a reflection of better
identification in a previously
underserved group okay because in the
prior samples that led to that CDC data
we actually saw that children of color
were under identified now as a
professional we know that symptoms of
autism and autism diagnoses affect
racial groups equally yeah
um and so we needed there was a call to
action to say we need to better identify
autism in racial groups that are not
being identified because detection and
diagnosis leads to intervention services
the more studies within those
communities will reflect uh more
diagnosis um so what advice do you have
for families that might have just found
out that their child
has autism and are concerned because
back in the day what the film back in
the day if you got the diagnosis it was
devastating to hear as a parent yeah
absolutely and it's usually the first
time parents are hearing and
experiencing autism so it's an
incredibly scary place to be as a parent
so the first thing I do with parents is
I always validate how they're feeling
and I let them know that it's a normal
reaction to feel overwhelmed to have
feelings of grief potentially feelings
of blame all of these feelings are very
normal their face they're in a world now
of uncertainty but I let parents know
that early identification and early
intervention has come significant has
just it's just transformed in terms of
where it used to be decades ago so we
know that individuals with autism lead
beautiful and fulfilling lives we know
that there are going to be some things
that they are not going to learn as
naturally as they're typically
developing peers but that's why we're
identifying that they have autism and
formulating a treatment plan that's
going to help them learn those skills
and help their parents understand how to
really parent them in a way that's
individualized to their own strengths
and those kids could be extremely gifted
in other areas yeah yeah um Cynthia
Martin thank you so much we appreciate
you to